I'm here with Chris yes nice to see you
mark to see you too you spent a lot of
time hanging with Kurt Russell yes he
tell you a lot about actually punch not
just for a convincing fight scene but
specifically for the camera yes he kind
of taught me to be aware of where the
camera is and understand the pieces that
will be usable he nailed it every time
and I almost never nailed it and he
basically coached me on how to do this
and we nailed it like that so always
know how to do that that's just one of
the many examples of things that you
learn when you work with her and I
caught just in the hell do you think you
are well any of icons zoe saldana Gamora
are there any um pitfalls to
interspecies dating or benefit quill is
a big fan of the female Ian he's like
she's not the first female Ian he's been
with the pitfalls are maybe cultural
differences that he doesn't quite
understand perhaps for him because he's
such a pop culture earthly pop culture
reference guy his whole ideology is
based on icons from the 80s she doesn't
know what any of that stuff is so when
he's trying to articulate his feelings
or express his emotions he's talking in
metaphors or if that just goes right
over her head so you know inability to
communicate might always be trouble for
people who come from different parts of
the earth for space and so communication
might be an issue but you know the
universal language love is the
and so it's a language that requires no
words I know it almost hit
[Music]